I am typing in
the final few lines of my brand new
tool, which by the way is 100%
free, which is showing up on your screen
right now. This is something I built to
help you get started when it comes to
planning your speech. And so I just
filled in the last line, and what you
can see here is there's simply seven
questions that you fill out. What is
your speech topic? I said best man
speech. Who is your audience? A wedding
with 80 guests. What's the occasion?
Wedding. How long is your speech? 5
minutes, which is a good length for a
best man speech.
What's your experience? Are you a
beginner, intermediate, advanced? For
this I put intermediate. What's your
biggest fear? General speaking anxiety,
but you could choose forgetting your
lines, not sure how to structure it, or
an other. And when you click other, it
will give you the opportunity to fill in
specifically what that fear is. I'll
stick with general speaking anxiety, and
then what's one thing you want the
audience to feel or do after? And I
said, I want to honor my friend who is
getting married and ensure the guests
enjoy the speech. So then I click build,
and the Speech Ready platform, which
again is an absolutely free tool that
I've built, is creating your customized
speaking plan. After about 20 seconds,
you get your result. It takes a few
seconds to think, and then boom! All of
a sudden, you have a full speech
outline, you have potential opening
hooks, you have a close. So let's really
dive in and see what this advice looks
like. So what it suggests for the hook
of the story is to open with a memorable
story or moment that captures your
friend's character. What a great piece
of advice. And this tool is trained on
all of my videos that I have made in the
past, and I often talk about the
importance of starting your speech with
something that's going to capture the
audience's attention, and a story is the
perfect place to start that speech, the
perfect way to jump right in, because so
many speakers will come up to the
microphone and do a informal
introduction about themself. For those
who don't know me, my name is so-and-so.
That's how most speakers will approach a
wedding speech. But if you jump right
into a story, that can be very powerful.
Then it talks about the body. So share
how you met, what made the friendship
special, focus on one specific story
that shows the character. A great idea
to keep this within a 5-minute speech.
Tell the story of how he met his bride
or how you witnessed their love grow.
This is a great way to ensure that
you're respecting the other person, the
partner who he is marrying, and you get
to speak both to them. Even though it's
mostly about the best man, or sorry,
about the groom, you still get to speak
to the partner, and a good way is to
share the story or at least your POV of
how you saw this romance take place, and
offer heartfelt wishes to them for their
future together. This is part of the
body, and I love this because it's
naturally built out a five-point speech
structure, which is something I talk
about often. You have the intro that
hooks the audience's attention, you have
three points within the body, and then
the close ends with a toast that brings
everything together in celebration.
That's the idea of the full circle
ending. Whatever you mention at the very
beginning of your story, circle back and
mention that at the very end as well. So
far, great advice from this tool.
Okay, let's dive into the opening hooks.
These sometimes are a little bit hit or
miss, and I'm curious as you start to
use this tool, let me know in the
comments what was good advice you got,
what are some ways that this platform
can improve, but it gives some
interesting suggestions. So an opening
hook, when groom's name told me first
met someone special, I knew it was
serious cuz he actually started ironing
his shirts. All right, a little light
humor to start. I think the idea here
with all three suggested hooks is it's
trying to get a little bit of laughter
from the crowd, and that's important,
because when we're giving a wedding
speech, especially if we don't speak
very often to groups of people,
we are nervous. We have anxiety, and so
the quicker that we can get the audience
to laugh, that is a universal sign that
they are enjoying themselves, and then
we the speaker will relax as well. And
what else is great is when the audience
is sitting there, they're wondering how
many speeches are there going to be? Are
these going to be interesting at all? So
the quicker you the speaker can get the
audience to laugh, they are going to
relax and totally immerse themselves in
your speech. The next suggestion for a
hook had a had a little poke at the
Leafs.
The I've known groom's name for X number
of years, and I can honestly say I've
never seen him as happy as he is today,
well, except maybe when the Leafs
actually won that playoff series. Haha,
right? Little bit of humor, which is
okay for a wedding, because people are
looking to laugh. I still think the
approach of diving straight in with a
story is best, but if you're really
stuck, that's what these opening hooks
suggestions are for. Okay, and then you
can dive into five personalized tips.
Practice your toast ending at home with
an actual glass in your hand, hold it up
for two beats, and then deliver the
final line. This is really important
because audiences will often remember
the first thing you say, and then the
way your speech ends. So you want to
make sure both of those are incredibly
dialed and 100% memorized and ready to
go.
The next is write out the speech word
for word. Okay, but then, this is the
important part, break it down. So get
away as quick as possible from the word
to word to bullet points, and
eventually, maybe just a word that
triggers you to remember what the next
part of your speech is, because the best
speakers and the best speeches do not
use notes. It's all up here, and you can
have little cues or triggers, but
ideally, you want to practice enough so
you don't even need to read off of those
notes.
Pick one person in the crowd who's
smiling, make eye contact with them when
you feel the anxiety spike. What a great
suggestion to get that comfort and that
confidence, look at that person who is
giving you that energy back. I love this
idea. Number four, keep a glass of water
nearby. Don't drink too much during the
speech, but sometimes your mouth does
get dry, you might want to use it, and
hydrate well beforehand, and end every
story or point by connecting it to the
bride or the groom's name, always
ensuring that they are the focal point
of the speech. Some very interesting
tips, and again, this whole tool is
trained on all of my YouTube content
from the past, so it's picking and
choosing ideas I've talked about over
the last five or six years and bringing
it into this tool.
And then it even gives you a pre-speech
warm-up routine where you can focus on
doing your full speech, and then smooth
transitions between the points.
There's some stretches, it talks about
rolling your shoulders back, taking deep
breaths. Wow, look at this. Practice
your opening line, closing line five
times each. It's giving you reps, so you
are as prepared as possible. I'm so
proud of this tool and the fact that it
is free and completely accessible to
you.
It's not going to be 100% perfect, but I
think it's a great starting point
anytime you want to take on a speech,
whether it's a wedding speech, a
business presentation, whatever the
speech is, you fill out those seven
questions to give this tool the context,
and it will deliver you with a
customized speech plan. At the bottom
here, you'll see a link or a call to
professional. Maybe you're a business
professional or an executive or somebody
who really wants to do a great job with
your next speech. This is my digital
store where I offer one-on-one private
coaching in some of these instances. So
this one, the speech coaching for
executives, three one-on-one calls. I
also do a custom speech evaluation, so
you send me your speech, and I give you
a customized video dissecting it with my
own opinion of how you can make that
speech even better. I run consultations.
If you're thinking about running a
podcast, launching a podcast, if you
have an existing podcast and you want to
make it better, this is something where
I'm really able to dissect what you're
doing well and what you can improve
upon. I have a $4.99 wedding MC
checklist, and another free tool. Lot of
freebies coming out from this video,
which is a public speaking guide, the
top 10 mistakes and how to fix them. You
enter your name and your email, you're
getting that guide for absolutely free.
A final thing I wanted to mention on
this video is that all of my YouTube
videos are now blog posts as well, and
they can be accessed by this URL. It's
going to be in the show notes,
blog.wadepattersonspeaker.com.
This is my YouTube blog, and the
opportunity to take any one of my
videos, maybe you're somebody who likes
to read rather than watch videos. Well,
all of these videos have been produced
in text form, full blog articles. Again,
this is more free content that is
available to you. One of my great
passions in life, in fact, a mission in
my life, is to help empower as many
people as possible to give them
confidence to communicate effectively in
front of groups. So, that's why I wanted
to make this video about these tools I
built that are free. All of my YouTube
content's free. All the blog posts are
free. And now there's this Speech Ready
tool, which is another free tool to help
you out as well. And that is my goal and
my passion is to help you out, give you
the tools necessary so that you can
communicate confidently.
I've thought a lot about the future of
where businesses and industries are
going, and I have this strong belief
that communication skills are only going
to get more and more important over
time. So, let me know. Try out the
tools. How did they work for you? What
was good advice? What advice could be
improved upon? I can continue to iterate
and make this tool better and better,
but I wanted to offer all of you, all of
my loyal subscribers and anyone who has
landed on this video, more value because
you have inspired me to create this type
of content. I get great joy from it. And
so, it's the least I can do to say thank
you. Let me know what you think about
the tools. Also, there's a video popping
up right now. This is what YouTube is
recommending that you check out. A great
piece of content for you to keep going
and down the rabbit hole. And I would
also ask that you subscribe to my
channel. It is the single best way for
you to support what I'm doing, but also
to allow yourself the opportunity to
continually stay educated, stay
up-to-date on my latest content, with
the ultimate goal of making you the best
speaker possible.
Thanks so much for watching this video.